Google glass and sex we talk a lot about
Google glass and I'm a firm believer
that this really is going to completely
change the way we react and if you think
you're being recorded all the time now
just wait til everyone's got it on their
glasses and their contact lens and all
that so of course it's being used for
sex and porn purposes there was an app
that was going to be on Google s called
tits and glass so that you'd be able to
stream pornographic images and videos
right through the Google glass it was
originally banned on the store then they
brought it back but the newest app is
called sex with Google glass and this is
so that you and your partner can both be
wearing Google glass having sex and you
could actually stream what the other
person is seeing as you're having sex
with them so that's right you could
basically be having sex with someone and
watching yourself have sex the entire
time unfortunately we don't have any
video of this yet I guess in the old
days this was just having a mirror on
the ceiling pretty much so what do you
think here so Google glass is this is
this thing gonna be as big we'll get to
the sex stuff in a minute but do you
guys think this thing is going to be as
big and change as much as I think yeah
but I don't think it's gonna be the
Google like everyone's not necessarily
gonna be wearing this ridiculous
designer on dance wearing Google glass
and they just did teabag you by the big
neon sign over their heads um you know
people can't walk and text at the same
time I can't imagine how they're gonna
go through life with while streaming and
being connected you know I don't I don't
know the word that multitask oriented
although it's sort of helped because now
you know there's pee everyone's looking
down and people are walking into
fountains and tripping on things and
getting hit by cars at least you'd be
able to walk up one other thing I forgot
to mention so the video that you can
record on this thing will stay on your
Google glass for five hours and then
we'll disappear which also seems bizarre
to me because usually if you've had sex
for five hours you're okay without sex
like you don't need to watch it again
maybe the next day or something like
that but you know porn always is like an
early adopter thing of what happens with
the next technology porn helped give us
online payment systems spam streaming
content VHS live video chat DVD
HD format and broadband all sort of were
born out of people wanting to watch sex
what do you think about this
disappearing idea that the stuff is
gonna disappear does anyone believe I
mean we've talked so much about the NSA
today would you ever believe that
anything you put out there now is going
to distribute no no okay next question
yeah yeah number two I think maybe even
people if you're looking to record all
this as you said the five hour span
people I don't want it to disappear
necessarily do that right at that point
then you're gonna have to get an
external hard drive if they can set it
up so that you can see how disappointed
your partner is with your performance I
think that might be useful otherwise
this seems incredibly sort of such a
narcissistic way to have sex that you're
focusing on yourself even though you're
looking at the other person with the
thing and it's that I've made this app
an argument before about on the main
show about how we're just so connected
everything now and I'm one of them but I
keep resisting every layer of something
that seems more ridiculous so like you
know we're zapped out the word jammed
into these things and sex now is not
even sex anymore so all this is creating
there must be a lot of really bad people
in bed because all you thinking about
I can't imagine well some of the terms
that you do to activate this Google
glass on okay Google let's go or pull
out okay yeah those are the words you
used yeah I don't care how hot you are
you come miles and you get my bed and
put these [ __ ] glasses on it go
there's some element that you would
never want to I think people like the
idea of seeing themselves have sex but I
videotape myself having sex once a long
time ago and I play it it it was on an
old-school like mini DV camera and then
I plugged it into you know regular
television and everything stretched and
it was horrible
but I think it's the idea that people
this might be good not doing it's not
stretched in the right way that I'm
making my wires were crying I don't like
your
my own voice unlike in my voicemail
thing oh yeah I do not want to see
myself having sex no good can come of
that I'm sorry so you have no this
doesn't appeal to you in any way no I
don't know and like I said I'm gonna be
I'm making a great old man because I
would be complaining about every new
technology and I complained about TiVo
before that huge I was like I want to
want something that hasn't happened yet
and then I was like okay fine it sounds
pretty awesome
you know it's ended up embracing a lot
of things I thought was that I thought
was stupid eventually wound up having
something to in its favor I'm sure at
some point Google glass will come up
with the the killer app was like oh
that's why this thing exists great sign
me up but until then it just seems kinda
predictable right and also the stuff
sort of creeps up on us so fast it's
like you know right now with your cell
phone you would never pick up a phone
call you always know who's calling you
but it was only ten years ago but you
might have had a landline that you it
would be like a ticking time bomb now if
you never knew who is who is there at
the other end right so is there any
chance that I'm wrong about this and
Google glass will become like the next
Segway remember everybody thought we
were all gonna be riding around on
little segways and now I see one guy
doing it here where I live all the time
and it's like but so you saw people at
Sundance and did you think and now it's
still on the early side and they could
have both been Google employees for all
I know so you know there's in the beta
testing guys I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
make us stands like no this is not going
anywhere because you know I don't want
to be the these newfangled horseless
carriages aren't going anywhere you know
but I'm dubious until they come up with
something that makes it you know
necessary yeah you with them on that mr.
old man who technologies gonna make
that's gonna make ways because we keep
we used things up so fast now we need
new ways to have the cell phone going
because everyone has one and it's
another way to have another connection
and we need something new now that's
just what we're expecting